i really see it as a as a celebration of
love i mean that's what it is which
sounds very corny
i think ultimately the audience come out
going
hell i think
[Music]
it's an assault on the senses i mean not
everything about it
it's quite unlike anything i've ever
done i've seen i was looking at the
monitor at the end of the day and i
thought
that's me in the middle look with nicole
kidman and i'm from creif
in scotland and look at that look at
that
the moulin rouge represents a world in
which christian who is played by ewan
mcgregor
he wants to be a bohemian he wants to
discover life
and so it represents sort of the
underworld he comes into this
world and is absorbed into its sort of
crazy wild fantastical
atmosphere
[Music]
and he meets this girl who's a courtesan
and falls in love with her
and convinces her that it's all right to
fall in love with him
it's a love story you know it's a it's
blatantly and unashamedly romantic
right i love that i love that more than
anything really suddenly
my life doesn't seem
such a waste
it all revolves around you
she's fantastic she's just wonderful and
we we've we're having such a good time
and um what can brilliant is together i
think yeah yeah
there's a slight height difference there
you know there was a lot of different
other stuff that we had to learn yeah
it's been fun
it's been a lot of work we've got
knocked back a lot at the beginning of
the film
nicole was an injury they'd never broken
a bone so it was sort of a
bit of a shock because they do a lot of
um lifts in the movie
doing it over and over again over a
period of you know
a couple of months
[Applause]
and i was being thrown and caught around
here
and being caught there over and over
again i kept dancing i didn't quite i
didn't realize i'd even broken it for
five days
yeah i thought i'd pull the muscle i'm
doing things in a corset that
no woman would ever have done in the
1890s
[Music]
and really it's one it's one of the
brilliant things about making films
anyways you never know until you've cut
it all together
if it's gonna work and more so than this
than ever before but
i have a very very good feeling about
[Laughter]
[Music]
this
foreign